so I asked them to be available via
phone so we're going to check it right
now with two of my guys I'm talking
about Dave Chappelle and Chris Rock
ladies and gentlemen
yeah they're gonna pick up
they're gonna pick up
hey
hey
Dave Chappelle and Chris Rock uh where
you guys at right now
we in o h i o the Battleground State
homie wow you know I know you didn't
graduate college yeah why did Dave spell
it like I didn't know it Ohio that's the
thing we do in Ohio but I scream my old
age crowd gonna say I owe cause it's
just the Ohio call you actually had two
people here that uh that said exactly
what you did uh they don't look like
they have a ride so I don't know what
that situation is but they're the first
lady herself she called me she said Kev
I need you to hold me down I want you to
host this special for me and it's about
it's about voting you know it's called
voter miss out we're encouraging people
to get out and be active to vote simply
be heard have a presence and I said let
me call my guys because I know what you
guys are doing but I just wanted to
check in I don't know why she didn't
call you all the host maybe she didn't
think about you whatever not my business
maybe she did okay all right that's not
that's not funny Chris that's not funny
that's not funny all right enough